what is going on everybody welcome to
part 6 of my SEO tutorial in this part
we're going to be talking about putting
yourself up on bing com now just like
Google you don't have to do this but it
can be helpful to go ahead and sign in
to you know like just for the same
reasons you wanted to be a part of
Google and submit your sitemap to Google
you would want to do the exact same sort
of things to bing yahoo in bing are best
buds so i actually yahoo search and bing
are just tied together it looks like so
as the organic search listings on yahoo
search are now powered by bing in the US
and canada and you should use Bing
Webmaster Center to do it so there you
go there's your answer and that is
straight from yahoo in case anybody
wants to check me anyway so yeah all the
more reason why you want to put yourself
on things so the way you want to do this
bing.com / web master / and if you're
not already logged in you'll have to log
in if you want to count well you'll need
to make an account next thing you want
to do is add your site so let's add the
URL of my sight sent that I can't type
at all oh my gosh anyway said there's
com add it and now you're gonna have to
fill in all this stuff you can put your
site map in here let me just copy and
paste mine all the way in here this is a
question here when you receive the most
traffic for your site now you could just
say all day if you don't really know
mine would be 9am to 5pm it's a most of
people use my website for stocks so 9am
to 5pm is the most popular time you can
put your information in here me llamo is
Harrison kinsley i'll leave my email
their job role founder
centex company organization sighs a
million industry financial services
contact oh my goodness I'm not putting
that in there everybody be calling me
from YouTube to put any other good to
put any of that stuff in there easily
put your country of origin United States
I'll leave that on for now I worry of
spam but hopefully not how often would
you like to receive message you probably
leave that on to give you like crawl
errors stuff like that up here we go
crawl errors sitemap index issues
malware that's pretty good because a lot
of times people can if you get hacked
one of the most popular things would be
to put malware on your site so that will
tell you save so then here is bunch of
different ways that you can verify that
you own this website so definitely want
to add the cname you can either upload
their little Bing site off that XML to
the web server and they looks like they
want you to put it right there in the
key so I'm gonna do that real quick all
right I did that let's confirm
successful by visiting that and the
browser's make sure that worked looks
like a Dave so verify prefer cool so
once you're done you should find
yourself on this page right here we've
already basically in the process
submitted a sitemap now I actually have
multiple sitemaps so I'm going to go
ahead and do that now and for anyone
that's curious it's kind of up in the
air whether or not multiple sitemaps is
actually of any use to you at all so I'm
not going to cover that in this video
you can research it and decide for
yourself whether or not multiple
sitemaps is useful or not so any
I'm not going to cover that I'm going to
go ahead and add my multiple sitemaps at
the moment and then we'll resume alright
so I've added all my site maps here and
just make sure you've added at least one
of your site match straight to Bing for
now we will come back to this Bing
Webmaster later but for now that's
basically all I really want to do just
get you set up started on bin you can
kind of look through this various stuff
i would really wait until they get your
little URL submitted last crawl on any
statuses and stuff like that wait to
really get to that point first but yeah
you definitely want to do this also as a
quick side note Alexa also has a decent
dashboard where you can add site so i
can add my site to it you can go into it
for free at least and edit your own
sites listing and then you can also buy
various things one number i'm really
sure i would suggest that you pay for
any of this but you can Kenley sign up
partially for free so we'll add sent
Dexcom continue and again you can do the
file download or you can add a
verification ID so you can choose which
way you wanted to do this once you've
done whatever you need to do it should
give you this successfully claimed
continue and then you can add some stuff
here obviously they're like you can't do
this it as it is but at least you can
add in some of this stuff so once you've
filled in some of this stuff obviously
just saving continue the process and
then you can add it any edits to your
site will be reflected immediately go to
the dashboard and then we're here I
pretty sure that's just a image that's
not true that's not true and that's not
true so anyway um that's pretty much all
you can really do at this point with
Alexa all you really need to do is well
you just kind of want to claim it looks
better on Alexa anyways so anyways
that's it uh with Alexa and adding your
try to ping bings a little bit more in
depth I don't think we'll get back into
Alexa at all besides just doing what we
did here and but being we will get a
little more in depth later just want to
get you added as always thanks for
watching